mesdames messieurs merci
de votre présence
donc on a le plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui l'Agence nationale de
sécurité de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail à savoir
l'ancienne dans le cadre de des travaux
de notre mission d'information sur la
gestion durable de l'eau
et donc nous avons monsieur Mathieu
Schuller directeur général
du pôle Sciences pour l'expertise
madame Éléonore né chef d'unité
d'évaluation des risques liés à l'eau
Monsieur Eric VIAL
directeur de l'évaluation des risques et
Madame Sarah auberti chargée des
relations institutionnelles donc merci
de d'avoir pris sur votre temps pour
cette audition donc cette mission a pour
lancer ça plutôt pour mission de
principal d'évaluer des risques pour la
santé et pour l'environnement
que nous font courir des produits des
aliments des pratiques et l'eau entre
entre
toutes et c'est vrai que c'est une
préoccupation forte pour l'anxess qui
vient de publier d'ailleurs un rapport
sur les polluants émergents dans l'eau
potable
donc nos échanges vont certainement être
très riches et on a une heure d'audition
que nous avons prévu et l'audition donc
du jour fait l'objet d'un compte rendu
et d'une retransmission puisque les
propos tenus ici sont bien sûr public
donc cette
mission d'information a été constituée à
la demande du groupe socialiste du Sénat
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains dont le rapporteur est mon
collègue Hervé gilet et qui comprend
comme c'est une mission transpartizone
transpartisane comme nous le faisons
régulièrement au Sénat et qu'on prend
des sénateurs et sénatrices de toute
sensibilité politique
alors c'est vrai qu'on a commencé les
auditions depuis le mois de février je
sais pas combien d'auditions nous en
sommes Cédric pour un nous le dire mais
je crois que ça fait déjà une
quarantaine donc on a on est à peu près
au milieu du milieu du gué
et on a prévu
comment un peu plus oui il y a encore
pas mal hein et on fera aussi bien sûr
des déplacements sur le terrain on sera
dans le dans le Cher lundi prochain
ensuite nous irons dans les Deux Sèvres
en Gironde
on avait prévu un déplacement à
l'étranger mais ça va être plus
difficile et donc on a prévu de rendre
ce rapport
début juillet
donc il est évident que si on n'a pas le
temps de d'avoir tous les éléments et de
des réponses à toutes les questions
qu'on va se poser et vous pourrez nous
faire une contribution écrite comme ça
on aura les éléments factuels donc avant
de vous laisser un temps de 5 à 10
minutes alors 5 minutes on va dire parce
que pour proposer je passerai ensuite la
parole à notre rapporteur qui a donc une
liste de questions que vous avez
certainement entre les mains donc on va
essayer de d'avoir un échange assez
parfois synthétique parce que si on veut
garder le notre heure parce qu'ensuite
nous avons les Q âgé les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement donc on a
des obligations de s'y rendre en tout
cas merci à vous encore une fois
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires c'est à
landeces de vous remercier pour le temps
que vous consacrer à ce sujet qui
effectivement m'a occupe une partie des
agents scientifiques de Lancel c'est
également des experts que nous
mobilisons puisque dans ces différents
travaux lancés travaillent bien sûr avec
avec ses équipes mais également avec des
experts du monde scientifique que ce
soit d'établissement public d'université
que nous que nous engageons dans nos
travaux pour lorsque nous sommes amenés
à formuler des avis je serai vraiment
très rapide pour vous ensuite vous
permettre de vous laisser le choix de de
parmi les différentes questions que vous
nous posez de voir celles sur lesquelles
vous souhaitez qu'on approfondie c'est
effectivement on apportera une
contribution écrite en complément de
l'audition elle est déjà elle a déjà
commencé à être préparé donc lances
c'est une agence de sécurité sanitaire
elle est elle est sous tutelle de 5 de 5
ministères travaillent agriculture santé
environnement protection des
consommateurs effectivement ce que l'on
voit à travers cette ces différentes du
thème c'est que préoccupations c'est
bien entendu l'ensemble des
connaissances scientifiques au service
de la sécurité sanitaire et pour cela
finalement on met en oeuvre différents
métiers que ce soit des métiers de
recherche et de référence à peu près les
moitiés des effectifs de l'agence vous
avez parlé monsieur le Président d'un
récent en rapport qui est le qui a été
produit par un laboratoire le
laboratoire d'hydrologie de Nancy qui
effectivement un laboratoire dont
l'existence remonte à avant l'anxess et
qui travaille sur tout ce qui est
référence en matière de contrôle des
eaux mais aussi en prospective d'où ce
type de rapport et puis au-delà de ces
missions de recherche et de référence
une autre exploitation finalement des
connaissances scientifiques c'est
l'expertise c'est à dire de rassembler
l'ensemble des éléments qui sont
disponibles à la fois dans la
littérature scientifique publiée aussi
auprès de donner qui peuvent être
fournies par des acteurs économiques en
responsabilité de le faire mais
finalement à partir de ces connaissances
et donner scientifiques de formuler des
avis en appui au décideurs aux
politiques publiques que ce soit
ministère de tutelle en complément de
deux autres missions je dirais qui qui
sont importantes des missions de
vigilance dans différents domaines des
vigilances nous ont été confiées pour
finalement au-delà de ce que nous dit la
littérature scientifique captée des
signaux qui méritent attention et
éventuellement actions ou réaction de la
part de des acteurs publics et ça depuis
2015 également dans certains domaines
nous ont été confiés des missions de
décision individuelles dans le domaine
notamment des produits
phytopharmaceutiques ou des biocides
alors pour passer rapidement à l'eau
l'eau c'est un sujet qui paraissant
transversal c'est l'un des trois milieux
dans lequel auquel les humains sont sont
en compte confrontés ou en contact
permanent l'air l'eau le sol ils ont
chacun des propriétés différentes les
polluants dans l'air passent de manière
plus rapide ce qui veut pas dire qu'ils
ne sont pas préoccupants vous le savez
dans l'eau il y a par contre des
propriétés c'est à la fois un milieu qui
est très mobile mais qui peut aussi être
un lieu d'accumulation évidemment c'est
un sujet de préoccupation quand on se
quand on se pose la question de la
durabilité de ces usages et le troisième
lieu dont on parle un peu moins qui sont
les sols qui eux sont encore plus je
veux dire de nature à retenir un certain
nombre de facteurs de risque plus
polluants ou de contaminants chimiques
évidemment si l'eau elle est elle est
concernée par différents métiers de
l'agence comme je le disais tout à
l'heure expertise recherche et référence
et on a à cœur d'y apport d'y apporter
une approche globale en matière de santé
puisque finalement que quand les
molécules chimiques ou des agents
microbiologiques ou des agents physiques
viennent interagir avec l'humain les
animaux ou le végétal les molécules ne
savent pas si elles sont si elles nous
rencontrent dans le cadre de la santé
environnement ou de notre ou nos
activités professionnelles alors que
bien entendu les codes et les textes
réglementaires eux sont sont par domaine
donc voilà ce que je pouvais dire ce que
je mes collègues rentreront plus en
détail sur effectivement
un certain nombre de cadres qui ont déjà
été posés par la réglementation
française et sur lequel l'un de cesse a
été en appui notamment du ministère
chargé de la santé sur différents
problématiques de réutilisation et mais
ça c'est quelque chose qui est plus
large c'est à dire que c'est évidemment
souvent mobiliser par ces ministères de
tutelle desquistes de circularisation de
l'économie des milieux et de l'eau
puisqu'effectivement qui dit
recirculation dit aussi potentiellement
concentration de de certains de certains
facteurs de risque et donc même si le la
motivation allait tout à fait pressante
elle est encore plus pressante depuis
ces derniers mois vous le savez bien
pour réutiliser que ce soit de l'eau ou
d'autres formes de ressources c'est
évidemment à nous qu'on pose la question
de savoir quels sont les moyens les
précautions les les points d'attention à
avoir pour que ces usages de
réutilisation se fassent de manière sûre
voilà ce que je pouvais dire en quelques
en très rapidement en propos liminaire
de manière à pouvoir ensuite mais l'idée
n'était pas de rentrer à ce stade là
dans les dans les différentes questions
peut-être vous vous laissez nous
indiquer celle que vous souhaitez en
traiter en traité en priorité je vais
laisser la parole à notre rapporteur des
gilet
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
on remercie aussi mes collègues pour
leur participation alors c'est vrai que
l'objet de la mission résonne
particulièrement sur la séquence où nous
en avons tous conscience avec une
sécheresse hivernale qui s'est aussi
affirmé et des interrogations
particulières sur l'exercice
2000-2023 alors sur ces sécheresses qui
engendrent aussi des concentrations
aussi plus fortes dépolluants bien sûr
parce que les quantités sont moindres il
y a des questions de fonds qui se posent
aujourd'hui qu'on vous a transmises
alors peut-être nous donner des éléments
de réponse sur les sujets qui sont les
plus saillants en l'état actuel des
choses donc justement sur la la
concentration des eaux on voit bien au
niveau des
des champs captant les problématiques
aujourd'hui de pollution qui commence à
se poser ce qui induit sans doute demain
et après-demain des zones de protection
de plus en plus fortes
donc le sujet
en l'occurrence à illustrer en termes
d'actualité justement ces sujets là donc
vous pouvez peut-être nous donner
quelques éléments aussi un peu
d'explications puisque c'est ce sujet-là
fait débat aujourd'hui et il y a des
controverses et des rapports de force
qui qui s'institue d'ailleurs ces
rapports de force sont de plus en plus
nombreux bien évidemment
sur ces sujets là
sur la réutilisation des eaux usées
effectivement
dans le cadre de l'énoncé du président
de la République sur le plan o on voit
bien les objectifs qui nous sont fixés
mais vous pourriez peut-être nous en
dire aussi un petit peu plus sur votre
vision des choses aujourd'hui au niveau
des usages puisqu'il y a déjà certaines
possibilités mais certains usages à
caractère plus industriels ou dans
l'agroalimentaire peuvent poser aussi
des des questions mais on voit
aujourd'hui que l'approche des ARS c'est
très pourrait-on dire
prudente même hyper prudente puisque
c'est souvent le manque d'avis conforme
des ARS qui empêche la réalisation des
eaux usées aujourd'hui donc vous avez
peut-être des des éléments particuliers
à nous donner par rapport à ça et puis
on voit également dans cette première
série de questions sur les stratégies de
stockage de l'eau qui sont des sujets
effectivement importants on voit
également des expérimentations en termes
de recharge de nappe qui est aujourd'hui
se mettent en place donc il semble que
vous ayez effectué des travaux en la
matière est-ce que vous pouvez également
nous en faire part on va déjà démarrer
sur cette première batterie et puis mes
collègues rebondiront bien sûr et puis
moi-même je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur alors pour
commencer sur le S métola clore donc
effectivement on a lancé ça a récemment
rendu un avis le prix une décision de ne
plus autoriser à nouveau le S métola
chlore alors l'histoire si ça peut si ça
peut vous être utile de reconstituer ce
cheminement parce que c'est juste c'est
pas une décision qui est qui est venue
comme ça le S métola clore est une des
substances herbicides les plus utiles en
utilisant en France et depuis déjà de
nombreuses années elle était largement
détectée dans les prélèvements qui
étaient faits dans le cadre des
contrôles sanitaires ce qui a conduit la
DGS à nous saisir en 2021 concernant
cette substance et de là c'est enclenché
un processus en trois étapes le premier
processus a été pour nous de regarder la
réalité des des contaminations de l'eau
de tout type ce processus a été engagé
dans le cadre de notre dispositif de
Phyto pharmacovigilance puisque en
complément des autorisations a priori on
a des évaluations à posteriori dans le
cadre de notre dispositif de Phyto
pharmacovigilance on a rendu un rapport
en 2021 sur cette substance qui
concluait effectivement à une présence
importante du smectoloclore notamment
dans les autres boissons mais
globalement dans tout type d'eau de là
est venu la seconde étape fort de cette
ce constat ce signal de phytop vigilance
la direction de la direction en charge
des autorisations de mission de marché
de lancès à ses saisies de ce signal
pour réviser les conditions d'emploi du
S méto la chlore pour les ajuster pour
essayer de diminuer autant de faire ce
peu les tout en tout en maintenant un
des efficacité des produits les emplois
de cette substance dans les différentes
cultures et la troisième étape qui a
suivi c'est en parallèle s'est engagé
une une révision enfin oui une
réévaluation de par anticipation de la
révélation niveau européen une
réévaluation de l'autorisation en
prenant en compte ces modifications des
conditions d'emplois et en suivant le
dispositif européen c'est notamment une
méthodologie européenne
la direction donc en question chez nous
a conclu que avec même avec ces
conditions d'emploi
réajustées les critères d'acceptation
n'étaient pas atteints puisqu'on avait
des polluants des concentrations dans la
nature phréatique dans les eaux
souterraines évaluées qui étaient
supérieurs aux critères d'acceptabilité
au niveau européen d'où la conclusion de
dire finalement la substance ne peut pas
être autorisée
donc là on est sur de mémoire c'était la
fin de l'année dernière
c'est récemment que au niveau de
l'écaille à une décision de classer
cancérigène
de probable pour pour l'homme
qui
entraîne des réflexions encore plus
fortes
puisque autrefois ce n'était pas classé
cancérigène donc on le retrouvait dans
les milieux mais il y avait moins
peut-être
d'impact pour
oui oui tout à fait après là là on est
sur au regard des évaluations qui qui
ont eu lieu dans le c'est quand même les
problématiques de contamination aussi
par ailleurs de contamination des
métabolites donc des sous-produits
finalement gérés par la substance active
dans le milieu des contenus de
contamination bien trop importantes de
l'environnement et qui peuvent induire
après des risques au niveau aussi
également de santé publique sanitaire
pour viser la qualité de l'eau potable
la problématique autorisation de
produits
européens on est
dans les mêmes normes
européennes c'est où on a un degré au
dessus alors on peut peut-être deux
éléments d'abord le caractère
cancérogène aujourd'hui il est
effectivement à l'occasion des examens
des substances actives puisque ça c'est
une des caractéristiques des produits
phytopharmaceutiques c'est que leur
permis de conduire n'est pas donné pour
avitaméternam il est donné pour un temps
limité donc la précédente date de 2005
l'examen en cours donc réexamen des
données scientifiques dans la précédente
délivrance autorisation effectivement il
n'y avait pas de classement cancérogène
d'ailleurs toute façon les classements
cancérigènes s'ils sont avérés c'est à
dire de niveau 1 la substance n'est pas
autorisée et effectivement aujourd'hui
le classement de la substance n'est pas
cancérigène avéré il est conseillé
probable niveau 2 c'est une gradation
dans la pesée des poids des preuves
scientifiques et c'est aujourd'hui pas
ça qui conduit
une agence en fait à retiré produit
c'est de dire que la quantité le taux de
transfert vers l'environnement malgré
c'est ce qu'a dit Eric Vial le fait que
les conditions d'autorisation a été
restreintes ce taux de transfert trop
important conduit à ne pas respecter les
critères européens alors qui sont
intervenus il est vrai après
l'autorisation de 2005 les critères
harmonisés date de la de la fin des
années 2010 de 2000 donc ce taux de
transfert est reste trop important et
c'est ça qui conduit au retrait
évidemment le fait d'être un cancérigène
probable pour la substance active parce
que ce qu'on retrouve dans les nappes
c'est pas la substance ce sont ces
métabolites donc le fait d'être cancer
avec une probable effectivement renforce
l'idée mais c'est pas ça qui l'a fait
sortir des critères de conformité au
regard du règlement européen et pour ce
qui concerne les autres pays votre
question monsieur le Président en fait
il a de toute façon les autres pays vont
appliquer une fois la Commission
européenne aura pris position sur la
base du rapport de l'EFSA donc de les
gens européennes
de sécurité des aliments et ça va être
appliqué de manière relativement
homogène mais aujourd'hui ce qui ressort
du rapport de FSA c'est la même
conclusion que l'on de ces c'est-à-dire
le problème principal de non conformité
de la substance ou de conformité dans ce
cas du genre examen c'est ce taux de
transfert trop important vers les vers
les autres
alors si on reformule c'est parce qu'en
France le taux de transfert relativement
important que ces décisions ont été
prises mais par contre le taux transfert
n'étant pas à ce niveau là avéré dans
d'autres pays la France est le premier
pays à le faire
et l'Europe est aujourd'hui en train de
parce que c'est pas excusez-moi mais
c'est pas clair pour tout vous dire
c'est pas clair et quelle est la liaison
avec la réglementation riche sur
le taux de transfert en fait quand on a
un processus d'autorisation il est
modélisé c'est une modélisation un
calcul si vous voulez et donc il est le
même qu'on soit sauf si on a des
variations importantes de ou des
différences importantes de climat ou de
sol ce qu'on appelle les conditions
pédoclimatiques mais
ça dans son dans son rapport considère
qu'effectivement en prenant les
conditions nominales qu'on trouve dans
différents points d'Europe consiste fait
le même constat que nous à savoir le
taux de transfert est trop important je
pense que la différence c'est ce indiqué
tout à l'heure Éric Vial c'est que
finalement en France on a détecté plus
tôt peut-être parce qu'on a des
contrôles plus denses plus suivis
la traduction de ce taux de transfert et
c'est le signal de phytopharmaco
vigilance qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
c'est à dire l'identification de cette
présence importante à de nombreuses
entreprises
donc c'est des avéré que dans d'autres
pays européens le taux de pénétration
est aussi important il y aura les mêmes
la même réglementation s'appliquera pour
en limiter l'usage je pense même qu'elle
va s'appliquer dès la finalisation du
processus de décision européen lève ça
donc si vous voulez l'équivalent de
lancer au niveau européen a rendu ses
conclusions à la au début de cette année
en février et elle passe le parent
l'image elle passe le relais à la
Commission européenne pour prendre la
décision qui qui s'ensuivent et à mon
avis la même conclusion va arriver
devrait arriver à la même décision
parce que conduire une interdiction au
niveau européen
et pour le coup la France du fait de sa
situation de l'analyse de sa situation
peut-être et dans ses droits d'être
précurseur par rapport à ça qui peut le
plus le moins
c'est un peu le paradigme il se trouve
qu'on est le seul pays européen à ma
connaissance qui est un dispositif de
phytopharmaco vigilance c'est-à-dire ce
mécanisme qui entre guillemets est à
l'écoute de ce qui peut arriver comme
élément événement indésirable ou élément
de contamination des milieux en amont
indépendamment de ce qui a été vu au
niveau de l'autorisation
oui tout à fait et au-delà de ce
dispositif de phytopharmaco vigilance il
y a même au niveau de la surveillance de
la qualité de l'eau potable donc tu es
par exemple qui prend en compte le
contrôle réglementaire assuré par les
agences régionales de santé on est
également des pays européens qui
recherchent le plus donc au niveau des
substances actives et des métabolites
donc ce qui nous permet voilà de pouvoir
se dire voilà de faire un état des lieux
les plus complets possible sur la
contamination de l'eau mais également
qui dit recherche d'y trouve
notamment une de vos questions qu'on
abordera peut-être tout à l'heure
monsieur rapporteur c'est les campagnes
d'occurrence des émergents
j'évoquais donc la réglementation riche
donc la réglementation riche en fait
elle
coexiste avec avec celle des substances
actives utilisées en dans les dans les
produits chimiques ou dans les biocides
en fait il y a le choix qui a été fait
par le législateur les législateurs
nationaux puis européens c'est de dire
certains produits sont soumis à
autorisation c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut
pas les utiliser avant qu'il n'ait été
examiné et auto et autorisé on utilise
parfois un terme en anglais qui dit no
data ou market pas donné de pas de pas
d'accès au marché et et de son côté le
règlement REACH lui pour les substances
chimiques en général il y a quel que
soit leur domaine d'usage est un
règlement un petit peu différent là
aussi les industriels ont comme
responsabilité de d'apporter au niveau
de l'Agence européenne des produits
chimiques des données sur les
différentes caractéristiques de danger
les différents modes d'action et de
toxicité des substances mais il n'y a
pas d'autorisation qui est derrière là
où les deux agences coopèrent c'est à
dire
c'est lorsqu'il s'agit de classer les
substances et notamment classer les
dangers typiquement lorsque dans le
cadre du réexamen de la substance active
s métola chlore le travail de classement
pour dire est-ce qu'il est cancéreux
cancéreux etc est-ce qu'il est
reprotoxique et ce qu'il est mutagène et
ce qu'il est toxique pour
l'environnement est-ce qu'il est
bio-accumulable cette évaluation là elle
est effectivement posée en coopération
entre les cas l'Agence européenne des
produits chimiques et lève ça l'Agence
européenne de la sécurité des aliments
d'accord réglementation donc européenne
qui est en cours de pardon qui est en
cours de redéfinition et qui devrait
peut-être aboutir donc avant les
élections européennes à la rentrée vous
avez des éléments d'information sur ce
sujet là pas vraiment sur alors pour il
y a deux volets pour les substances
chimiques il y a un premier règlement
qui est un petit peu moins connu
peut-être qui est le règlement CLP pour
classification étiquetage emballage
celui-ci il a déjà bien engagé son
évolution et parmi les progrès qu'il
fait il y a notamment l'intégration de
nouvelles classes de danger une classe
de danger dont on entend souvent parler
parce qu'elle préoccupe nos concitoyens
c'est la perturbation endocrinienne qui
avant n'était pas dans le règlement CLP
qui maintenant va y être par contre le
règlement REACH le deuxième règlement
que vous mentionniez monsieur le
rapporteur lui il est encore en
réflexion et moi j'ai pas de boule de
cristal pour savoir si effectivement les
services de la Commission vont avancer
suffisamment rapidement avec les avec la
représentation européenne pour conclure
avant ou après le changement de
mandature bien on a du mal à voir des
informations un peu plus précises au
niveau du calendrier sur ce sujet
peut-être pour boucler un peu la
question sur les métaboliques et sur ce
qu'on recherche nous nous sommes
effectivement aperçus que le spectre
d'observation a été différencié en
fonction des ARS ce que l'on peut
comprendre dans une approche
territoriale où on peut observer plus
facilement certaines familles de
molécules contenu des Usages industriels
agricoles donc ça peut s'entendre mais
on a du mal à déterminer aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui
cristallise le choix véritablement du
spectre observé par les ARS par chacune
des ARS donc est-ce que vous êtes des
éléments d'informations à ce niveau là
et ce qu'il y a des process d'évolution
des plans de contrôle qui sont prévus
dans ce cadre dans ce cadre de figures
sur le choix des molécules qui sont
observées
premiers éléments tu pourras compléter
c'est difficile de se prononcer la place
derrière mais il y a une figure à poser
au niveau du contrôle sanitaire après
chaque ARS peut compléter cette figure
imposée par des substances qu'elle va
qu'elle va sélectionner compte tenu de
de l'environnement il y a un comité
scientifique comment ce choix est-il
opéré parce que vous le savez peut-être
que vous ne le savez pas
il y a pas de comité scientifique
effectivement c'est illéga maintenant
désormais au niveau national
moitié des méthodes d'analyse
suffisamment robustes pour pouvoir avoir
confiance dans le dans le résultat que
l'on retrouve
bien voir si nous avons compris ce
serait un peu inquiétant ça veut dire
que si sur une zone de compétence ARS il
y a pas les compétences pour rechercher
certaines familles on va pas aller
chercher non c'est pour ça que je
reformule les agréments des laboratoires
sont prononcés au niveau national et en
fait les ARS ont la capacité à aller
chercher la compétence auprès de
n'importe quel acteur qui d'ailleurs ce
sont des marchés publics donc
effectivement il y a après là où il peut
y avoir une impasse c'est sur une
molécule qui serait nouvelle on n'a pas
forcément une technique qui a la
performance qui va bien et mon propos
c'était de dire que finalement
maintenant les listes sont très longues
il y en a vraiment beaucoup on recherche
beaucoup pour le coup on doit on n'a pas
c'était centaines de molécules qui sont
recherchées à chaque fois dans le cadre
du contrôle sanitaire
bien merci mes collègues avez-vous des
peut-être des questions à poser parce
que je pense que si on veut
essayer de
faire tourner les les questions sur un
certain nombre de sujets on n'a pas
parlé des eaux usées et on n'a pas parlé
de
la qualité des réseaux enfin bon
merci allez-y Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs merci du
temps que vous avez bien voulu nous
consacrer j'aurais eu une question une
de vos missions notamment consiste à
évaluer les risques liés à diverses
pratiques dans les zones de protection
de captage or on s'aperçoit que d'année
en année la diminution du nombre de
captage est de plus en plus importante
est-ce que nous avons failli quelque
part est-ce que nous les abandonnons
parce qu'ils sont pollués est-ce que ou
est-ce qu'au contraire vont peut-être
fait de la surprotection qui fait que
nous ferons des captages qui pourraient
être utiles
on peut allez-y monsieur ouvrier oui moi
j'ai une question de savoir où en sont
les études sur les vous parlez des
molécules classées en différentes
catégories de risques quand sont les
études sur les effets cocktails sur les
molécules compte tenues du grand nombre
de molécules aujourd'hui chercher mais
aussi trouver parce que vous avez des
résultats et puis l'élu d'Île-de-France
est intéressé par la question neuf sur
la question de l'osmose inverse basse
pression si jamais il vous restez un
moment dans l'échange pour me donner
votre point de vue
bien non
mais écoutez allez-y
alors merci pour votre question quelques
premiers éléments se base sur les
captages quand on a des évaluations de
risque à faire en lien avec des demandes
d'autorisation on évalue les risques il
y a il y a des positions qui sont prises
des compléments qui sont à porter et
donc le positions finales que l'on enfin
nos conclusions se fait finales
elles portent sur les risques de
contamination possible des captages du
fait de l'environnement et de la
répondre fermeture des captages utiles
nous nous fermons pas des captages nous
évaluations nous évaluons les risques et
nous nous positionnons quand un risque
possible de contamination des eaux qui
sont qui se récupèrent au niveau de ce
captage quant à la fermeture c'est une
c'est une mesure de gestion
oui allez-y juste préciser oui parce
qu'on a de nouveau de nouvelles
situations qui se mettent en place
notamment avec beaucoup de fermes de
panneaux photovoltaïques qui sont
implantés un peu un peu partout et
aujourd'hui le risque voilà il y a
beaucoup de on dit beaucoup de choses la
presse sans part pas mal du sujet en
disant est-ce que c'est une source de
pollution ou au contraire est-ce que
c'est neutre est-ce que pour vous ça va
ne faire qu'aggraver cet effet de
diminution du nombre de captage je
rappelle au passage qu'on était à près
de 34000 captages qui produisaient en
gros 18 millions de mètres cubes de
d'eau potable ce qui est quand même pas
négligeable pour le pays ce qui
d'ailleurs permet d'avoir de l'eau
potable dans tout le pays mais on
s'approche petit à petit des 33000 des
32000 donc voilà est-ce que on en ouvre
pas de nouveau donc du coup est-ce que
pour vous vous sentez cette cette
décroissance du nombre de Carthage et
est-ce que vous allez vous renforcer
encore une fois c'est pas vous qui
fermez j'entends bien vous préconisez
mais l'ARS le fera
après de notre de notre côté et regarde
nos missions on n'a pas de on peut pas
avoir la remontée de tous les de tout ce
qui se passe au niveau terrain de les on
n'a pas ce niveau là donc on peut je
pourrais pas m'engager à vous dire que
on a cette vision là globale nationale
au-delà de ce que de des informations
qu'on peut réitérer via des rapports
justement qui nous donne ces
informations et après des échanges qu'on
peut avoir justement avec des services
locaux mais par l'intermédiaire je
dirais à l'occasion de de dossier que
l'on traite et de dossiers locaux qui
pourraient nous être remontés donc par
exemple effectivement sur les projets
que vous évoquez on peut être amené à
être sollicité c'est pas une obligation
c'est le préfet qui au cas par cas sur
des projets locaux va décider que
effectivement la ville lindset pourrait
être pour être requis et dans ces cas là
notamment quand il y a des projets qui
se donnent lieu dans des périmètres de
protection des captages où il y a des
prescriptions à réglementairement
effectivement il y a des obligations et
des prescriptions en particulier dans
les périmètres de protection immédiats
et rapprochée
on est très attentif à finalement
l'ajout d'une d'une d'une
qui serait non réglementé l'impact
potentiel sur la qualité de l'eau donc
là on peut penser dans le sud de la
France dans le Valais d'aull et
finalement au niveau du lac et quel sera
les risques
de la dégradation de la qualité de l'eau
au regard de toute cette nouvelle
activité des interactions qui puissent y
avoir sur la plante la qualité de l'eau
et puis éventuellement donc il y a le
risque environnemental mais que nous
nous prenons à la marge au regard parce
que c'est pas le cœur de la mission de
l'enss c'est d'autres d'autres agences
donc oui oui on est on est très attentif
et on est très attentif après on n'a pas
émis forcément de position je dirais
national parce que comme c'est souvent
le cas on pourra reparler via peut-être
les zones en conventionnelles il y a
quand même beaucoup de cas par cas donc
avoir une une position globale sur tous
les projets qui pourraient se faire
c'est très c'est très complexe et il
nous faudrait d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'avoir beaucoup de de vue de finalement
de retour d'expérience sur différents
types de projets pour éventuellement
faire ressortir une directrice globale
et des points d'attention
si vous voulez bien donc effectivement
nous là on va être saisi c'est
éventuellement sur des dans des
situations où les gens continuent à
vouloir utiliser un captage malgré le
fait qu'il était contaminé on a dans ce
cas-là des autorisations exceptionnelles
qui sont instruites et confiées dans
l'instruction scientifique et technique
et confié à l'agent dans ces cas-là
souvent ce qu'on préconise quand même
c'est au-delà du fait qu'on installe des
filtres ou des dispositifs pour
finalement restaurer la qualité de l'eau
d'un captage dégradée c'est quand même
de réfléchir en en partie je dirais en
deuxième voie de en deuxième roue de
secours à investiguer d'autres captages
et quelque part la réflexion que
j'aurais par rapport à votre question
c'est de dire peut-être que par le passé
on n'a pas su on n'a pas été
suffisamment large dans la
dimensionnement des aires de protection
et c'est finalement c'est quand on va
constater un moment donné qu'une
ressource est contaminée c'est peut-être
parce que ça avait pas été taillé assez
large si vous permettez l'image et sur
le sur le cas des problèmes
photovoltaïques enfin des sujets
photovoltaïques on a effectivement ont
été missionné pour examiner une
situation particulière et nos experts
après avoir regardé notre avis sur notre
site c'est sur la Durance si je dis pas
de bêtises et à ce moment-là les il faut
regarder vraiment les matériaux qui sont
employés et ce qui a un risque de
finalement de transfert de contamination
et la conclusion avait été négative donc
il était possible de d'installer ses
équipements d'accord sur l'effet
cocktail peut-être quelques quelques
éléments bon de toute façon c'est un
sujet sur lequel d'une manière générale
le monde des risques qu'ils soient
chimiques ou biologique ou physique
s'interrogent c'est-à-dire qu'on a
effectivement des processus ou des
procédures très précises pour examiner
chaque facteur de risque sa toxicité et
à partir de quand la toxicité va
s'exprimer ce qu'on appelle un seul ou
une valeur de référence sanitaire après
les c'est plutôt du domaine de la
recherche de savoir est-ce que deux
substances qui sont utilisées côte à
côte vont finalement l'une attaquée par
le l'image c'est très imagée
Morgan et un autre l'une le foie l'autre
le Rhin et finalement pas d'interaction
particulière ou est-ce que au contraire
on est susceptible d'avoir un effet de
synergie ce qu'on appelle du coup en ce
que nos cost citoyens appellent
facilement l'effet cocktail l'effet cet
effet synergie ou additif il est pas il
est pas si fréquent que ça quand on
regarde un petit peu les travaux de
recherche
par contre ce qui est fait de manière
souvent prudente c'est que même si on
n'a pas le l'affirmation que les effets
s'additionnent les scientifiques quand
ils ont des des facteurs de risque de
d'exposition simultanée les ajoute et
typiquement dans le domaine de l'eau et
les eaux destinés à la consommation
humaine vous avez aux côtés de la limite
de qualité qui est 0,1 microgramme par
litre pour les pour les pesticides on
dit que en plus la somme de tous les
pesticides doit pas dépasser 0,5 donc si
vous voulez sans avoir toutes les clés
scientifique la réglementation a déjà
posé un jalon de prudence en disant bah
voilà quand bien même il y en a s'il y
en avait plus que 1 c'est pas chacun des
10 substances à droit à 0,1 c'est 0,5
pour tout le monde voilà donc ça c'est
une traduction concrète alors ensuite on
poursuit bien entendu notre travaux de
recherche pas que tout seul aussi bien
au sein de l'agence et également dans le
cas d'un gros projet de recherche
européen qui s'appelle Park Park c'est
partenariat pour l'évaluation des
risques chimiques donc qui nous est qui
est un une grosse initiative co-financée
par la Commission européenne et les
États membres pour à peu près 400
millions d'euros c'est une somme très
importante sur 7 ans et qui est là pour
essayer de voir comment on va mieux
évaluer les facteurs de risque chimiques
notamment sous l'angle de cet effet
cocktail et pour la prise en compte de
l'exposé
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait des
réponses mes chers collègues ouais
j'avais juste une interrogation mais je
pense que mon collègue Hervé gilet
continuera dans les questions c'est sur
les eaux usées on est beaucoup portable
dans le en France sur la réutilisation
des eaux usées et parfois on nous dit
que c'est à cause des autorisations
sanitaires que la France n'évolue pas
donc
chacun essaie de trouver des
responsabilités
par-ci par la mais aussi le poème
technique évidemment qui est qui est pas
toujours simple alors quel est votre
réponse par rapport à cela
pour commencer
effectivement les
réutilisations de
usées ou de non conventionnels pour
élargir à d'autres
OS que les eaux usées traitées c'est
clairement face aux pressions qu'on a
actuellement sur les ressources en eau
c'est clairement logique qui est
important d'activer c'est un moyen de de
relâcher enfin de faire face à ces
pressions tout en répondant malgré tout
une attente très forte en termes de
qualité de quantité suffisante des
consommateurs donc par contre et donc
c'est cette inscrit dans le nouveau plan
le le plan le plan gouvernemental pour
les eaux avec une action une mesure
Visante maximiser la valorisation des
des zones non conventionnelles par
contre nous de notre côté nous
clairement on et c'est on s'inscrit dans
le cadre de nos missions oui une
recyclage ou une utilisation dont nos
conventionnelle mais dans la mesure où
les risques les risques liés à cette
activité à cette sont maîtrisées et
permettre de garantir la sécurité la
sécurité sanitaire de la consommation de
ces eaux et on a dû on a eu pas mal de
travaux alors peut-être Eleonore pour
on est là on évoquait quelques-uns et on
a des travaux en cours notamment dans le
cadre de ce de ce plan de ce plan
gouvernemental on est saisi actuellement
on a on a eu pas mal de demandes que ce
soit sur le recyclage la réutilisation
des zones conventionnelles pour
l'irrigation des espaces verts des
cultures dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire dans les usages
domestiques donc c'est ce sont des
travaux que l'on mène actuellement mais
dans le cadre de nos missions
d'évaluation des risques et
effectivement il peut arriver que on a
conclu que les risques ne sont pas
suffisamment ne peuvent pas être
considéré comme suffisamment maîtrisé
pour autoriser tel ou tel type d'usage
avec telle ou tel type tel ou tel type
d'eau
où est-ce qu'on trouve ces informations
parce que on a du mal à s'y retrouver si
vous voulez un petit peu dans ce dans ce
maquis et quand je parlais d'une d'un
avis conforme des ARS en fonction de la
nature des projets ça c'est bien une
réalité c'est à qui conforme d'ailleurs
il est souvent rendu par le fait qu'il
ne l'est pas
déjà en fait il y a une ouverture ça
l'utilisation des eaux usées traitées
pour l'irrigation donc agricole des
denrées agricoles et l'arrosage des
espaces verts donc ça existe en France
depuis ce permis depuis 2010 ça c'est
une ouverture qui existe depuis
longtemps de même pour une ouverture
réglementaire l'utilisation des autres
pluies pour un certain nombre de
d'usages
collectés en aval des toitures après
c'est vrai
nous l'appui qu'on a pu
et depuis peu finalement maintenant
grâce justement aussi un à des
verrouillages je dirais législatif et
réglementaire il y a une élargissement
du dispositif réglementaire qui est en
train de de se faire il y a des grands
champs différents chantiers qui sont en
cours pour justement permettre beaucoup
de façons beaucoup plus large d'autres
OS un propre c'est pour ça qu'on dit aux
non conventionnel on va bien au-delà des
eaux usées traitées maintenant on vise
aussi les eaux grises donc les oménag si
vous voulez eau de pluie autre process
au sein des industries et eau de
n'importe quel bâtiment même aussi j'ai
vu j'ai vu des autres pédiluve dans les
piscines des autres vidanges et pour
aussi bien d'autres usages et là je
dirais tous usage et ce qui est aussi je
dirais notable parce que je sais pas si
c'est intéressant ou pas mais en tout
cas ce qui est notable c'est aussi en
termes d'usage des usages urbains des
usages domestiques c'est à dire que il y
a un verrouillage pour certains usages
domestiques mais on a comme la
consommation humaine également ou
l'hygiène mais justement tout ce qui est
considéré comme usage domestique le
l'alimentation des chaises d'eau le
nettoyage de de sa voiture le linge
voilà où il y a des particularités et
des et des approches variées je dirais
lavage de la voirie donc ça c'est même
en externe ou au sein de son habitat
et là c'est vrai que on a été nous on
est amené à être saisi alors
au mieux en amont en fait de
l'élaboration de l'édifice réglementaire
c'est-à-dire faire une évaluation de
risque sanitaire pour ensuite pouvoir
proposer une structure réglementaire qui
soit la plus appropriée dans les faits
c'est très compliqué à on l'a fait sur
les eaux usées traitées on l'a fait sur
les eaux grises et on l'a fait sur les
autres pluies et dans les faits on se
heurte à des difficultés de réalité de
données en fait et de pouvoir
généraliser chacun est particulier et
maintenant qu'en plus on veut ouvrir
avec finalement il y a une volonté et
qui se comprend de pouvoir utiliser
plein de dos différentes pour des usages
très variés on va pas pouvoir avoir une
forcément un avis général sur sur
d'évaluation de risque générale pour
tout par contre pour autant il y a quand
même des prescriptions que l'on peut des
points d'attention pour nous en termes
de maîtrise des risques notamment être
au clair sur quand il y a un usage donné
pour pouvoir proposer une qualité d'eau
qui soit conforme à l'usage donné donc
plus il y a une exposition directe avec
l'homme par exemple plus la qualité de
l'eau doit être je dirais propre si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi et avoir des
exigences très fortes en termes de
qualité de l'eau avoir également donc
pour ça il faut connaître finalement la
qualité de l'eau en amont celle brute
celle que vous utilisez votre hotte
pluie votre user votre grise votre
process peu importe donc avoir une bonne
connaissance donc c'est le porteur de
projet qui a le meilleur c'est la
meilleure connaissance de pouvoir
finalement
identifier les dangers en amont
caractériser les risques traiter
proposer des traitements c'est le
souhait pour pouvoir derrière aboutir à
une eau qui soit compatible avec l'usage
exactement et donc et que donc il y a
une bonne maîtrise identification des
dangers et une bonne maîtrise des
risques et puis que derrière il y a une
surveillance proposée oui oui comme
certains pays sont en pointe sur ces
sujets là ils ont déjà traité ces sujets
la question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui
c'est
comment la montée en conscience
scientifique au travers de des usages
aujourd'hui qui sont mises en place dans
certains pays nous permet aujourd'hui de
consolider notre propre système parce
qu'on a le sentiment que le parapluie
français s'ouvre toujours de plus en
plus grand et que nous on crée les
impossibilités de mise en oeuvre et
qu'on ait le dernier de la classe quand
il s'agit de mettre en place ce type de
politique
peut-être un élément oui non mais
j'entends j'entends bien votre question
en fait le sujet qui est derrière c'est
finalement on part d'un point où
un certain nombre de progrès dans la
santé encore on a été fait avec
l'amélioration globale de la qualité des
eaux là je parle de décennies derrière
donc
et donc du coup aujourd'hui ben que ce
soit nos concitoyens ou que ce soit les
opérateurs économiques qu'ils ont
l'habitude quand ils tournent le robinet
d'avoir une eau qui est de qui qui est
de qualité aujourd'hui on se pose une
question différente et dire oui mais
celle-ci elle commence à manquer donc il
faut aller en chercher d'autres qui sont
peut-être de qualité inférieure pour
pouvoir soit les utiliser dans des
usages qui sont moins exigeants
exactement comme dans la réutilisation
des eaux pour l'irrigation il y a
différentes classes de qualité ça ça
même été mis au plat en place dans un
dans un texte européen et ensuite et
c'est peut-être là que moi j'ai une
vraie question c'est que nous ce sur
quoi on bute souvent c'est finalement
au-delà des plaquettes publicitaires que
peuvent avoir les vendeurs de procédés
mais quels sont les données sur
lesquelles il s'appuie parce que nous on
demande pas mieux et nos groupes
d'experts ne pas mieux quand il
travaille pour le compte de la Direction
générale de la santé sollicitée ou pas
par une ARS c'est que d'avoir des
données convaincantes pour dire oui on a
on part d'un niveau de qualité qui est
celui-là on veut atteindre celui-ci qui
est pas forcément celui de l'eau potable
et voilà la démonstration qui va avec
donc moi ce que je ce que j'identifie en
tout cas et c'est comme comme un point
c'est que d'autres pays ont peut-être
réussi à construire ce mécanisme mais ce
qui nous manque souvent et là je parle
de ce contrôle de mes collègues parce
que c'est eux qui coordonnent les
expertises mais quand moi je vois les
avis arriver il est fréquent qu'on lui
dise bah là j'ai pas eu assez donné pour
et ça ça perd du temps pour tout le
monde donc finalement les porteurs de
projets je pense que les collectivités
on leur dit ben voilà je vais vous
apporter tel procédé qui va vous aider à
récupérer de la capacité en eau bah il
faut que au-delà de la déclaration
d'intention il y a aussi des éléments
solides qui soient apportés en soutien
sur la transmission des éléments solides
en soutien en France alors
c'est une évolution des pratiques mais
je dirais pour tout le monde vous parlez
de pays finalement même pour l'Israël
monsieur le Président pour d'autres pays
mais qui sont qui font face à des
sécheresses et des problèmes de manque
d'eau depuis pour certains des décennies
alors qui se sont aggravés dans le temps
au regard des changements climatiques
mais qui était déjà des comment dire
habitués à des problèmes de sécheresse
et donc qui ont anticipé oui mais c'est
pour l'expérience de toute façon mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est
collectif je ne suis pas sûr que la
problématique soit uniquement du du
point de vue de des alertes tout en tout
cas des points d'intention en termes de
il y a quand même des réalités de risque
sanitaires si on ne si on y fait pas
assez attention mais peut-être qu'aussi
la formation et l'appétence à pouvoir
comment dire mettre en place ces
nouvelles ces nouveaux comment dire
c'est nouveau oui technologies cette
nouvelle façon nouvelle façon de faire
c'est pour tout le monde que tout le
monde sait en prennent conscience et la
bonne formation et je dirais que à tous
les niveaux peut-être aussi et sans
prétention pour les porteurs de projets
je ne dis pas qu'une maîtrise pas du
tout le leur leur projet je dis aussi
que pour eux et dans certains domaines
on peut voir dans certains domaines
industriels je sais pas moi par exemple
on va aller voir sur l'industrie agrumes
alimentaire et ensuite qui n'ont pas
forcément l'expérience du traitement de
l'eau du traitement de l'eau s'improvise
pas non plus les problématiques aussi de
stockage c'est à dire que quand on va
transporter l'eau transporter l'eau et
nous dans le domaine de l'eau potable on
le connaît très très bien il y a
toujours une problématique qui ne relève
pas forcément la traitement et donc
derrière de pouvoir arriver à la qualité
finale voulue ça d'accord mais de la
pérennité de cette qualité de l'eau et
ça dans le terme des stockage des
transports il y a à chaque fois des
points d'attention régulier à avoir
parce qu'il y a toujours des
dégradations de potentiels et donc
derrière en fonction de l'exposition
s'il y a pas l'exposition de l'homme je
dirais
vous risquez est limité et c'est pas un
problème si derrière des expositions de
l'homme le la population générale mais
également les travailleurs qui sont en
première ligne parfois en fonction de
certains de certains postes de travail
et bien donc il faut il faut les avoir
en tête il faut qu'il y a une vigilance
maîtrise des risques et le dispositif
associé finalement le porteur de projet
est celui qui connaît le mieux son
projet qui est le plus à même de
proposer et d'ailleurs la réglementation
va dans ce sens tout à fait mais mais
finalement quand il y a une système
d'autorisation derrière donc pour les
ARS ou autre
services de l'État et nous agence on
appuie quand on nous sollicite on n'est
pas sollicité sur tous les projets c'est
ces points là ou que regardons et c'est
vrai que si on a pas l'information c'est
toujours des difficiles de pouvoir se
positionner
au travers des questionnaires du
questionnaire qu'on nous a transmis il y
a un sujet que vous souhaiteriez mettre
en exergue avant que nous concluions
effectivement cette cette audition notre
collègue David Bruyer abordé là où se
trouve l'inverse pour la
reminéralisation qui était aussi un
sujet et Monsieur peut-être oui
rapidement parce que le temps nous est
compté d'un point de vue organisationnel
on sait bien que quand tout va bien on
n'est jamais trop mais quand ça commence
à les mal il y a toujours trop d'acteurs
parce que c'est pour les élus locaux
c'est toujours compliqué de savoir un
petit peu qui est responsable est-ce que
pour vous et c'est pas une question il y
a un animaliste ni est-ce que pour vous
l'organisation telle qu'elle est faite
aujourd'hui est la plus efficiente qui
soit comme comme on dit maintenant ou
est-ce que pour vous il y aurait des si
vous aviez une baguette magique demain
est-ce que vous auriez vous avez dit
dans vos propres pollinaires dépend de 5
ministères est-ce que tout ça c'est ça
peut se justifier mais en même temps
est-ce que c'est pas trop compliqué
est-ce que pour vous l'organisation est
la plus efficiente possible aujourd'hui
oui pour pour lançais on n'a pas de
difficultés avec le fait de relever de
cinq ministère je dis que c'est normal
compte tenu de la largeur du champ de
notre champ d'action et et de toute
façon ils peuvent être amenés tour à
tour à être nos candidats la question si
vous la posez au niveau local là par
contre j'ai pas forcément d'éléments de
vision mais ce qui est très important on
le voit sur des projets comme de la
réutilisation d'eau ça peut justement
être on est en train de traiter
actuellement un projet de texte pour les
pour la réutilisation d'eau dans les
industries agroalimentaires et en fait
les industriels agroalimentaires et
l'eau ça concerne deux services de
l'État au moins autour du préfet les
agences régionales de santé et les
directions qui vont les DDPP ou les ou
les drafts donc les directions
régionales de l'agriculture et qui eux
homologues les installations et là
typiquement dans la vie qu'on va qu'on
va rendre probablement en juillet
prochain on appellera la tension sur le
fait que c'est très important que ces
services interagissent parce que à un
moment donné on va on va réutiliser de
l'eau
code de la santé publique dans une
installation code de rurale et la pêche
maritime mais et l'importance surtout
c'est que finalement les acteurs de
l'agroalimentaire ils ont déjà une bonne
démarche en matière de d'identification
des dangers de maîtrise des risques mais
c'est qu'il faut qu'ils intègrent le
fait que maintenant ils n'ont plus
forcément de l'eau qualité consommation
humaine mais des eaux de différentes
qualités donc il faut faire ce et ça ça
peut nécessiter que les services en
local interagissent de manière assez
étroite
et alors sinon pour répondre à votre
question sur l'osmonaire la réponse va
être courte on n'a pas eu à expertiser
ce dossier donc on n'a pas de on n'a pas
de réponse à vous apporter en termes de
de pratique sur Essen de cette
osmose inverse et juste par rapport à
vos yeux qui est monsieur le Président
en début de séance le les fuites de
réseau
ça descend de la question est-ce que
c'est un facteur de dégradation de la
qualité il y a 20% de fuite
malheureusement
peut-être un peu plus donc c'est c'est
un facteur important de lutter contre
ces fuites alors je pense que c'est pour
nous le même si on n'a pas eu à regarder
cet aspect là mais la question elle est
sous l'angle de qualitatif parce que
leur quantitatif on connaît très bien il
a été audité plusieurs fois de plus en
elle-même pour nous c'est pas c'est pas
un facteur de dégradation de la qualité
ce qui peut être et c'est ça sur quoi on
est vigilant dans le cadre de nos
missions c'est l'utilisation
bien est-ce que vous avez quelque chose
à compter
on se mettrait bien sûr le complément on
a effectivement des réponses bien plus
aux différentes questions qui étaient
plus nombreuses que celles qu'on a pu
aborder dans le questionnaire merci de
nous adresser votre contribution écrite
disons début juin c'est au plus tard
parce que si on veut être prêt pour la
le début juillet il y a pas de souci
comme elle a déjà de réaction à faire on
a déjà une rédaction bien avancée début
juin devrait pas être et si jamais des
questions vous viennent à l'issue de
notre échange d'aujourd'hui à ce
moment-là faites-le nous savoir par par
l'intermédiaire de des gens qui vous
appuient dans la dans la dans la
secrétariat de la mission en tout cas
merci à vous de votre disponibilité
d'avoir bien voulu répondre à toutes ces
questions merci
merci
et au plaisir